ماسك قد يصنع هاتف ذكيا ينافس فيه ايفون
وسامسونج وغيرها من الشركات التي تستعمل
نظام اندرويد بالتاكيد منافسه عمالقه
التكنولوجيا ليسا امرا سهلا لكن من يصنع
صواريخ تسيء رحلات الى الفضاء لم يعجز عن
هذه المنافسه لكن رجل الاعمال الامريكي
ومالك منصه تويتر يامل الا تصل الامور الى
هذا الحد وان لا يضطر الى هذه الخطوه
الدافع لتصريحات ماسك هذه المره عن
امكانيه الحديث عن حذفت تويتر من متاجر
التطبيقات جوجل رد ماسك في تغريده على
حساب المذيعه الامريكيه المحافظه
التي قالت ان نصف البلاد ستتخلى بسعاده عن
التطفل والتحيز الذي تقوم به ايفون
اندرويد و غردقه الرجل يصنع صواريخ للمريخ
يكون الهاتف الذكي الصغير سهلا اليس كذلك
طرحوا هذا الموضوع ياتي في وقت تشهد فيه
تويتر الكثير من المشاكل بعد تسريح عدد
كبير من الموظفين والثقاله اعداد كبيره
منهم ايضا ما دفع العديد من المعلنين
الكبار الى التهرب والهرب من تويتر حيث
ظهرت مخاوف بشان الافتقار الى الاشراف على
المحتوى واعاده المستخدمين المحظورين على
المنصه منذ السلاح ماسك على المقصه
[موسيقى]